BUT BABE, MOVING OUT?
PLEASE, THIS
IS THE WORST POSSIBLE TIME.
PLEASE DON'T DO THIS.
BABE?
[sighs]
- GARBAGE.
- HUH?
- CAN I TAKE YOUR GARBAGE?
- YEAH, SURE.
- [chuckles]
YOU KNOW, I FIND
THE MORE GARBAGE IN THE CAN
THE BETTER IT FEELS
TO DUMP IT ALL OUT.
I SUPPOSE THAT'S
WHY WE LET IT GET SO FULL
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO WE CAN START OVER.
- HERE TO FIX THE COPIER.
- YEAH, SURE, SURE.
HEY, HOW DID YOU--
- SOMETIMES THINGS
AIN'T REALLY BROKEN.
IT'S THE WAY
WE TREAT 'EM
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
[machine starts]
HEH.
[whistles]
[chuckles]
- WHO THE HELL
ARE YOU GUYS?
both: THE IMPORTANT QUESTION
IS WHO ARE YOU, STEVE?
[ominous music]
- WELL, IF IT
ISN'T MR. STANLEY.
- CARL.
[ominous music continues]
♪ ♪
- YOU NEED TO FIND
YOUR OWN TROUBLED WHITE BOY.
- I WAS HERE FIRST.
COPYCAT!
- AAGH!
[coughs]
[heavy breathing]
SWEEP THIS...
BITCH!
- HUNH!
- [chuckles]
UH-OH.
- HAH!
- WHOA! UNH!
[groans]
- [chuckles]
- DAMN!
CHESTERFIELD!
[whistles]
both:
THERE CAN BE ONLY ONE
MAGICAL NEGRO!
HUNH!
[intense opera music]
♪ ♪
- [wild whistling]
both: YAARRGH!
- GOOD LORD.
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
WELL, I GUESS SOMETIMES
THINGS HAVE TO COME APART
BEFORE WE CAN PUT
'EM BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
- OH, YOU'RE
A MAGICAL NEGRO TOO.
- WHO YOU CALLIN' "NEGRO,"
BITCH?